we want to go back to the first day that
you quote unquote quit Hollywood you can
remember that day do you remember some
of the emotions that you were feeling
Yes actually so at this time I was an
actor right and it was just acting
and it was the plan a I don't need a
plan B either I'm gonna make it or
that's it right a very naive of me but
it it got me a long way so what happened
was I was called out to this audition
and I drove from Orange County and I
drove to this to this casting I forget
where it was but it was somewhere by the
Universal Studios if I remember
and I remember having this inner
dialogue with myself and I was like all
right I'm gonna go to this casting this
is going to determine and I was like
talking to God I was like this is the
one either either I I booked this and
something happens or I'm done
and the sign on this day couldn't have
been any clearer to me that at this
moment in life the universe was like
this is just not right for you so I go
to the lot I said hey I'm here for a
casting I forget what it was for
and
they're like there is no casting
I said okay so I checked my email the
day is Right everything is right
last minute the casting director changed
the audition date to another day
so that was like that that was as clear
as it as it was and I was like okay I
got it I got the sign I'm done and
in that moment I kind of get goosebumps
now talking about it but in that moment
I was like all right well
this isn't for me and there was so much
time and effort where for that span
of like going auditions I was almost a
Power Ranger
um always getting callbacks
and
never quite getting that defining role
or or anything that could catapult me
and mind you at the time
this is what no one ever tells you
I was in the one percent of earners
in you know for like a good two to three
year stretch
but what you see on TV the Brad Pitt's
the you know Leonardo's they're the one
percent of the one percent
so the one percent of being a working
actor
what is that at the time it was like
twelve thousand dollars a year or
something like that and for a couple
years I was averaging like a solid like
40 000. I was doing like for me single
guy no wife no kid
I was like okay I'm doing something
but in that moment when I drove all that
way casting they they it did a few
things to me where
a part of me almost like
broke
because it the I've never had a signal
in my life just be so clear
it was just like
okay this isn't for you at this time so
when that happened and that switched
happened I took a couple years off
but something inside of me
I didn't see the change that I wanted to
see so when I first went out to
Hollywood this was straight out of high
school no family no friends no money
nothing like that I just left
and
I told myself I would be the Asian Will
Smith right and obviously when you go
somewhere you do something you want to
be the the first you that's always the
answer you hear from somebody oh I'm the
first me but you're always inspired by
someone or something and that's what
kind of fuels you to do something
so at the time it was Will Smith and I
was like I want that career
for myself
in hindsight
I wasn't ready for it I thought I was I
thought I had the looks I thought I had
the personality I thought I had the
charm
but I wasn't ready for it I was never a
good auditioner
uh I would spend all this time you know
going over lines non-stop that you go
into the room and you think about the
line so much that it deteriorates the
performance compared to just performing
and
in hindsight when I think about
what I did wrong because at the time you
almost feel when you see colleagues that
you've worked with and you see them
doing well and you see them doing all
these big shows that you auditioned for
and you didn't get and you see them
doing you know movies like Shazam and
all this stuff you
naturally you feel a certain way
but as you get older
and you mature as a human being
you become happy for their success
because that their success doesn't take
away from your success so when someone
succeeds you should always look at it
from a place of
well if they can do that I can do that
and use that as an inspiration to kind
of Rocket you to do whatever it is that
you want to do
you were 18 when you flew to Los Angeles
from where Georgia from Georgia okay so
you even though you've been raised
somewhere else yeah so I was born and
raised in Hawaii
um but you know my goal was always to
get out of the island so my mom at the
time lived in Georgia so after my
freshman year in uh Hawaii which was the
school was kale it's
[Music]
k-l-k-e-a-a-u High School uh I moved to
Georgia and we thought well in Hawaii
there's a saying like oh if you want to
better your life you go to the mainland
so my mom was in Georgia so I stayed
with my mom for my sophomore year to my
senior year
and fun there's a funny story about how
this led to me moving to LA
so when I was
Junior Senior High School my best friend
and I were into tuner cars our whole
group was into tuna cars
and on this night I don't even know if I
should be talking about this but it's
fine on this night uh we were driving
and he had like a a souped-up MX6 had a
koze motor swap and all that stuff and
then I had an MX3 nothing fancy but we
were driving side by side on the main
road and we were like talking because at
this age I was like really hyper I was
like hey what's up man we were just
talking and a cop pulled us over
uh and we got tickets for street racing
so my license got suspended
so I couldn't drive I forget what the
length was I don't know if it was six
months or a year I just I don't remember
but we couldn't drive
and upset because that's your freedom
right being able to drive is your
freedom as a teenager
uh my mom so all of this is is really
thanks to my mom because
she heard on the radio that there was
this acting school coming and the
school's name is John Roberts Powers at
the time I don't know what they're doing
now but at the time that's what it was
called
and they were at the radio and there was
this big convention center and everyone
brought their kids and it was just
packed it was packed I didn't want to go
I was like I'm not going to this stupid
acting thing because it's not anything
it wasn't with me as a kid I never
thought to myself oh I want to be an
actor I want to be a director I didn't
care right I was playing basketball
um but she forced me to go so we sat
down I don't know if it was the director
or the rep or whoever it was at this
event but he asked hey who can do this
commercial for me right now and for some
reason I just raised in my hand because
I thought it was dumb I was like yeah I
can do it it's not a problem so he said
okay I want you to pretend it's a baby
diaper commercial and you're putting the
diaper on the baby or whatever it was
I'm surprised I remember that
um and I did it no hesitation I just did
it I was like oh you know and and I
guess he was so impressed that I was
able to do it that he invited me to
their Atlanta location
um and he paid for everything so he paid
for the teachers he paid and my mom
would drive me in the mornings really
early like five or six a.m wait all for
the eight four to eight hours that we
were there and then drive back right so
she would wait and we did that for a
year and after that year there was a a
Las Vegas event called ipop at the time
and I uh they paid for me to go to Vegas
to go to the event and everything so
then I got an agent out there at the
time
obviously you're I'm naive at the time I
don't know anything I don't I'm like oh
I had an agent right from from Georgia
at the time it's not like now where all
the Productions are moving to Atlanta
but you just don't know you think I have
an agent I'm gonna be something
so
at this Crux in my life not having any
family members that graduated from
college not having anyone that
successful financially so they're at
that point there's no one to look to
it was like this is my golden ticket
this is how I'm gonna build a life right
um so once I got the agent and I
graduated high school I sold my rate I
had like this nice Boombox stereo I sold
it for a couple hundred bucks and then I
flew to to California
and that is how I ended up in California
where did you end up uh at the time it
was
I believe it's Hollywood Boulevard
Hollywood Boulevard and then I moved to
Granada Hills
and then Granada Hills I just kind of
went South the whole time like every
because
I got fired uh I was a waiter at Olive
Garden and I got fired because I saw a
pretty girl there was a guy at the table
with her and another girl and I'm I'm
assuming the guy liked the girl and I
asked for her number while I was waiting
their table and uh he complained and
then I got fired so when I got fired
everything kind of
crumbled because that was the way of how
I made money and she said something
sorry yeah he said something and being
18 with no skill set right it's like how
else do you get a job because
you have to balance between making it to
auditions
and working
so at that point it was like place to
place renting rooms couch surfing living
in the car going here going here just
kind of doing that whole thing for a
long time sorry did they did you bring
him extra breadsticks I mean to make
just
the pieces yeah you know
what oh okay there was no flirting
between them there was nothing I just
and being young sure you're 18. I was
18. and I I just saw a pretty girl and I
was just like hey what's up your Q
what's your name sure
um whereas in hindsight
it was well worth it right because I met
my wife and had our son and that's how
life turned out so it was well worth it
but at that moment it led to a lot of
struggling which I can't really blame it
on that because I have to take
responsibility I'm the one that
shouldn't have asked for a phone number
while working so it all comes back to
being my fault but that that that's the
Crux of how I ended up in Los Angeles
so do you mind if I ask how long were
you living in the car couch surfing so
though that was probably like a good
year that was probably like a good year
because what happens is and along the
way I had a lot of people help me out
right you don't make it living on
Couchsurfing living in your car and
stuff you don't make it on your own and
there's people that tip their head in
here and there whether it was you know
someone giving you 10 20 bucks whether
someone letting you stay on the couch
for a night I used to park my car into
the neighborhoods to go to sleep
so and there was a there was a couple
girls at the time that uh that let me
stay at their place and shower because
you know I didn't have money for a gym
membership to go shower at the gym so
you know every couple weeks or so often
they would let me kind of stay for a
night and then that was it and you kind
of just navigate and find your way and
the way it kind of worked I never had
credit I didn't have anyone that had
good credit I didn't have anyone that
had money so I couldn't say hey let's
get this apartment or this house
um
but what I did have was charm and just
perseverance so anytime I would get that
big commercial check right or and this
was the time I don't know what it's like
now because I haven't been in any
commercials recently but like at the
time when I did like a McDonald's
commercial or anything like that you
know I got like 20 30 000 for one day of
work that would last me
six seven eight months of rent and gas
and insurance to kind of make it to the
next gig right whereas now in hindsight
I'm like man if I got a 40 000 check
like that I would just put it down on a
down payment on a house rent out all the
rooms and then they have them pay for my
mortgage and then that way you can focus
on something else because your roof is
taken care of so no
sure but it took it took a while for you
to get that kind of financial literacy
yes yeah and a lot of hard hard breaks
oh no I was gonna say yeah that all that
all came because of my wife so
my wife
is much better with finances and she's
more successful than I am
and when I met my wife first day I met
her I told her hey we're getting married
and I'm giving you a boy we got married
and I gave her a boy oh wow and what she
told me there's a few things she told me
she said you're going to get life
insurance
right so I got life insurance and you're
gonna go back to school so I went back
to school for I.T
and now
my day job I'm I'm in I.T I'm a network
engineer
and that's how I made money so the by
her forcing me to go back to school I
took a loan on half and she paid for the
other half so really she invested in me
as her life partner
by doing that and getting that stability
I was very lucky because I had somebody
again help me along the way
to become the man that I am today it
didn't just happen by myself like yeah I
put in the effort you know studying and
making sure I show up and get things
done but it was because my wife said I
know you're capable of more so you're
gonna do more she was the wind to my
sail right as cheesy as that sounds so
by me going back to school getting that
stability now having a skill set
I'm able to create and do so much more
and and help Inspire other people
because I'm not worrying about where
food's coming from I'm not worried about
the roof over my head I'm not worried
about you know life not not to say that
there isn't things to worry about but
I'm just not worried about life because
I know
whether I'm working for somebody whether
I'm working for myself whether I get
fired tomorrow I have a skill set and
with that skill set you'll always be
able to make money to support your
family so with that stability as a
filmmaker and actor director producer
writer
you're able to create like never before
because you're not worried about the
struggles of life
so back to the earlier question when I
was an actor just a pure actor in in
Hollywood struggling
you couldn't really get as good as you
want to be because so much of your focus
is where am I sleeping tonight how am I
going to get food right and these are my
Ralph's chicken tenders with mac and
cheese days or that that was my meal
right
so once you're able to take care of the
core of living as a human being
you're able to fully Express Yourself
as a creator
that's excellent and a good point too is
when you have these quote unquote Gypsy
jobs here in LA's someone else's term
that I've I've stolen so Gypsy jobs
which are you know hey we need you to do
this promotion or whatever for a week
that's great and they can pay well but
then you have to look for new work and
you're always your time is spent looking
for work as well so same with acting did
you have a backup plan when you came to
La no and that in hindsight
that's probably one of the things I
would have done different
um obviously the life that we're on is
the life that we're on and things that
happen you cannot change but if I could
still have the life that I had today but
make some adjustments along the way so
that Journey was uh not as turbulent
I would have had a plan B
and even now being in the position that
I'm in now
filmmaking is a hobby until it generates
more than my career
and I tell anybody it's like hey if you
want this to be your number one then it
has to generate more than your current
number one because as a human being as a
father as a husband uh you have a
responsibility to your family to provide
so because I have a family I'm not 18 or
19 and if I were to give any advice to
someone that's 18 or 19 I'd say hey have
your plan B
and have your plan a and do that in
parallel
because eventually they can do this but
if you're if what you want to do as a
doesn't pan out then at least your B is
going to take care of you through life
because whether you succeed or whether
you don't succeed time is going to go
anyways
so you might as well pursue it but
pursue it the right way I see a lot of
times where younger people
and I was one of them
that say
I don't need a plan B I'm going to make
it on plan A
but what happens when you spend 10 12 15
years doing something and it doesn't
happen
right time goes by fast at one moment
you're 18 then you're 25 then you're 30
then you're 35 and it's like okay well
what do I do well
if you rock your plan a let's say this
is Hollywood right whether it's a writer
producer any anything creative this is
plan a plan B is uh you're a dental
assistant you're a real estate agent
you're a mechanic it doesn't matter if
you do this like this eventually
if this pans out and you give enough
water to this seed hopefully you can do
this right and this can now be the main
thing that you're doing
but
a lot of times where artists
tend to go wrong
is they don't see the show business of
it we all want to create and not talk
numbers but if something doesn't do well
then you can't sustain it
the business of Hollywood itself
wouldn't sustain itself if it doesn't
make money
so
I say all that to say this
if you want to be a producer a writer
director
there's two things
make sure you have food on your table so
if you're living with your parents stay
with them as long as you can because
life is just easier
and to just do it
just do it doesn't matter if it's a
small project big project big budget no
budget just do it because you're going
to get better as time goes on but if you
don't do it and you expect somebody to
just give you that handout but you're on
level zero there's no way you can get
the level 10 without going through one
through nine